[Music]
I don't understand if you're the one who
overbooked to the hotel
I usually accommodate the people that
you screwed over by finding them places
to stay no I just couldn't believe it
when you called me I thought to myself
happy Valentine's Day hey babe
Hey oh my god Wow uh we're doing
anything this here change it up I I know
I know that I just thought we would had
agreed to take things at face value to
not I'm sorry this is Kate I'll meet you
from college Kate Hudson travel mishaps
they overbooked my hotel it was this
whole thing so I bet she could stay here
tonight yeah we talked talked about
before hey we talked about Kate stay
home I mean doing nothing - not doing
anything right not doing anything is the
same as having your friend stay the
night all right listen hey you guys are
doing something I I think I could get
one of those pipe chairs just the other
day it's all my plans I'm scared I think
I think it would be better if I know
you're staying please I insist
you're saying okay so you definitely
can't add a third wheel tour a third
party to our reservation
I know it's Valentine's Day but I'd be
laughing too if i were you honestly the
cancellation fee even if I don't eat I
still have to pay 250 dollars but look
I'm not gonna shoot the messenger here I
mean that's a fair price all right well
thank you anyway so Kate what they have
to say it's looking like it's gonna be a
little tough to squeeze in a third you
talk to do you talk to the manager why
don't you two go together oh no we did
not let this reservation go to waste
this is like a once in a lifetime meal
you know you cheering you have been
growing right out as well I sit here
alone on
she's already off you know I'm actually
I'm pretty tired to have to work early
in the morning so I'm just gonna turn in
I'm just gonna she's tired tired yeah
all right let's get you tucked in bend
how could I have not predicted you're
gonna have a friend in town on
Valentine's night babe can I can I help
you you know I got a she's my mess I'm
gonna live in it so I'm gonna clean it
I'm gonna fold it you know I'm just
gonna I'm gonna run down to Waffle House
and just hang out there for a little bit
I'll be back and like it you hungry
set you up with some food come on it's
[Music]
wow you know if I had known we had
guests coming over tonight I probably
would have done a little bit of grocery
shopping cuz I got nada yogurt free hey
looks like rabbit medium egg noodles for
dinner you like egg noodles you got
peanut butter babe I don't I can I help
you get in there you took your shoes off
you're off-duty for the rest at night
you know what they put peanut sauce on
Thai stuff will do lepen Thais lipids
and yogurt to get out on creamy nobody
really asks you like her behind you
Valentine's Day tradition us three get
together every year I'm actually happier
eating here right now you made you
actually meet you you know what I like
find my spin cut sashimi the best
Valentine's day ever
Hey look yourselves this is 100% the
most dysfunctional relationship I've
ever seen in my life
this is hard to watch you guys just
should this is an oldie you should not
be together look you
I am so sorry no I'm sorry that we I
mean we open our house to you on
Valentine's Day and we let you into our
house we were cooking you a meal on
Valentine's Day what you're gonna tell
us how to live our relationship says the
girl who's single on Valentine's Day
every day was here to go I got it you
gotta go all right yeah how fun out
there yeah we're lucky yeah got that
right
I love you happy Valentine's Day let me
know
I need to go to the hospital
[Music]